belli belli sono proprio contenta perché
oggi sono perfetti ricci adesso vado a
dormire mi rilassa domani mattina
saranno tolto per l'incontro con kras
[Musica]
che cosa ho in testa
cos'è un mito ma non deve neanche la
pioggia erano perfetti ma perché li fate
questo che scontiamo la bomba stanotte
nel letto dio ma enorme non è neanche un
nodo resta come cavolo 99 sono scioccata
certo che questa potrebbe anche dar sono
la pettinata dai scarlato centrale ha
capelli lisci io ho i capelli ricci non
posso pettinarli ma anche senza nome per
tirarli nel senso che si ripeti o
somiglia da grid e qui preferisco ritare
scusami adesso seguiamo in volume che fa
tenere i capelli in ordine
metti non li becchino soltanto sotto la
doccia da bagnati sembra veramente ok ci
siamo ragazzi la scorsa volta mi siete
piaciuti tantissimo la volta prima però
non mi siete piaciuti per niente
eravate crespi disordinati indefiniti
quindi io non so so quali sono le vostre
potenzialità so che ce la potete fare
per favore è un'occasione importante
devo avere dei capelli perfetti
venite bene vi prego venite bene come la
scorsa volta è
ma che belli sembrano quasi delle molle
donna davvero sembrano proprio di
fusilli si giocherà tutto il giorno se
gli avessi anch'io mari ma vicina merita
ogni riccio un capriccio
io posso andare in giro così non è
illegale andare in giro così sembra uno
spaventapasseri
con tutti i soldi che spende per
attenuare l'effetto crespo e questo mini
set
e questo me ne inglese e questo non li
definisce abbastanza e questori unge
basta oggi ho dei rich tremendi me to
cappellino non ne voglio sapere scusa
forse il colore non so il modello
sicuramente questo mestiere ma stavo mi
sta sempre bene figurati se non mi chi
l'ha detto che chi ha i capelli ricci
non si può fare delle fatta sia
bocciature per esempio una bellissima
coda alta cosa sono cose
cosa sono sti bozzi e l'olio mica fatti
ma perché rifacciamo subito scaduto
come devo fare io come devo fare devono
storia ed uno vede storia in più basta
non ci mancava solo questa
i capelli in cappelli incastrate nei
nostri mari ma perché non ti ritagli un
po questi capelli perché perché nessun
taglio va bene perché i capelli ricci se
se li fai scalati risalgono troppo
quelli davanti e copro gli occhi ti
danno fastidio se gli fai pari se mi la
campana un triangolo premendo seri
taglio troppo sei troppo corti se vi
lascio lunghi appesantiscono e quindi va
via il volume è che ti devo dire niente
questi capelli così devono rimanere così
stessa cosa dura un lucidalabbra calza
scarpe ma vabbè ma non ci credo cos'è
sta roba
la lampada di aladino
beh comunque i capelli ricci sono
bellissimi e poco da lamentarsi ipoker
ma tu hai idea di cosa vuol dire gestire
i capelli ricci guardano per curiosità
le subire assumo brevemente la mia vita
allora anche se non sono sporchi nei
capelli bisogna lavarli dopo un giorno
perché il primo giorno sono belli belli
definiti rally vaporosi secondo giorno
fa non schifo quando scelgo il diffusore
cimetti dai 40 minuti a un'ora circa
dipende dalle convenzioni capello
ovviamente ogni volta mi si crea un buco
qui dietro ma io mi chiedo ma come sai
cos'è sto buco da dove viene
tutti davanti e dietro piatti poi
un'altra cosa che proprio non sopporta
che sembri sempre in disordine e non si
capisce perché poi da un lato sono in un
modo dall'alto in un altro da un lato
magari ricci belli e finiti dall'alto
flash in quel posto proprio indefinito
in simile glossari niente oggi meli
diastro e addio ai ricci non piove non
c'è umilità bello vedere i capelli lisci
ordinati
ho appena finito di piastroni posto di
nuovo ricci nessuno
[Musica]